in the previous episode no I press I
hope you are ready to kick some ass with
me if you want shut down anyone who Lou
you can do the first that's a dumb idea
where we came off of that this is a
scissor alright
investigate this area
I want her to know what to do I think I
played this in the last episode good
night
then I or didn't I know this is where
man said all right but I did actually
play this I just did it end up in the
video ah [ __ ] it went to investigating
here it doesn't appear to be anything
but skulls if I may correct you
[ __ ] but I think it's actually
here yep
whattcha heavens is that a skull dildo
disgusting I'll take it
thank you save it for later you never
know scholarships are fine
coaching Table nine I don't know what
I'm making money there there we go goody
knows how to play this game for the
faction excellent
it'll work now hey let's go [ __ ]
let's go [ __ ] things up over here oh no
I don't like this water is now gwenna
I'm trying to spend but it's not going
that well [ __ ] faster bro so stupid I
can literally do with a list of
ballerinas sup girl
hey so uh you want some other public
card hello ladies
what that oh no no what a show my cable
is stuck Mike
[ __ ] I think I lost all right I'm ready
no no Kelly oh wow defeat the
well I'm not a gentleman ha [ __ ]
milkman what you gonna do
papa no not again what up [ __ ] Smith
boy [ __ ] pick give me the hatchet don't
eat that [ __ ]
silver hatchet time what are they doing
I still a [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] she wants
shot in pennies all right that's a win
luggage [ __ ] what you gonna do oh [ __ ]
duck it pitch [ __ ] pocket ends way
mighty good that's regeneration
double what what is this [ __ ]
get out of there get out of there but I
get out of them what am i doing that's
better
ah [ __ ] it
oh shut up
die die die die die I cut your chest I'm
not there's this [ __ ] difficult ha ha
just ah you're [ __ ] next
[ __ ] what are you doing what
sick no my ass I need that [ __ ] give it
to me get it get it just what I mean
whoa check no no no not today not to
[ __ ] day
not today not today [ __ ] all
right yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you walk just
so finally feeling good job pity thank
you hi I [ __ ] did it that's fine
change and get out of here I'm exhausted
I could go for a sandwich I wish kids
would hear you have to make me one but I
love the picture wonderful that's a guy
giving birth to it to a giving birth I
guess that's enough to be weird
all right where the [ __ ] did we go I
want to go with in love I want that boat
my I guess we go here oh there's a
[ __ ] bridge shines through the bridge
you could have told me about the bridge
bro oh cool hi I don't have that much
energy left
but have it soon anyway Wow why did you
help me
Papa so did you get battle that's right
stupid barrels [ __ ] [ __ ] barrels
man oh there we go
say the content okay I did it
we we did it you just watch glide moved
and you said hear this you suck which is
good
smoke battle [ __ ] fine change I the hell
is she is that weapons at the window I
don't need windows why would I need a
window
but it what is this matter I want to
pull this switch first can I do that
no [ __ ] it let's go home and [ __ ] the
girl sup girl oh no it's one of those
disgusting lon
no [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
Oh they spit on her I need a weapon
Oh take the machete highbrow yes alright
now we can [ __ ] things up actually don't
don't you dare don't you dare woman ah
shut up
ah ah got an attack it was you huh [ __ ]
next one please
oh hello that blockage message hi what's
your name Anna don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got it there we go that's what happens
oh my god that's what happened that's
what happens when you [ __ ] with pentapox
next place right at this singing [ __ ]
go
alright let's just [ __ ] go in here
find Kate
alright whoa hello and Christmas
blah blah blah no no no ha ha ha no I
came back today - oh my gosh Dachau I
need you to back in the [ __ ] up sir
I said these don't last very long I
should get that tape back today all
right emerge from the forest and found
an ancient program my action more
animated from a collapsed wall on the
east end I managed to make my way inside
it was in the sort of place where once
simply Stroh's up the front steps and
whispered or better a gracious host or
paragraph greet you either the wrongness
of this place is palpable malevolent it
quiet said Alan Moore is a victim my
quarry here rather casts its gaze on the
intruder Quran and inhumane it's already
racing ahead of young Arthur sweat
perhaps thicken by fear and my curiosity
crawls down my brows as if it were blood
ok I can rely on nothing here but this
old semi-automatic pistol
I can't even remember when I find it
last me neither I checked that the clip
is seated again equip it hard to surpass
the dead
ha-hey from me carry Wow ha ha ha ha ha
ha and what else wonder fight
ha ha ha power saw
nah I prefer this it what's up I want
some crab same n yeah it wants a
persimmon that guy loved it
oh hello hi hey what's your name Nicole
oh [ __ ] you ha whoa
oh no it's one of the singing [ __ ]
don't you dare sing job the ha ha shut
the [ __ ] up please thank you shut the
[ __ ] up - shut the SCAF day whoa I
[ __ ] broke the [ __ ] on the phone
hi place hell yeah ah Jeremy gotta say
I'm talking to you [ __ ] I'm
gonna talk to you dad come here I don't
write oh okay
now get me out of here I can help you
okay
I'm nothing looks like an e Turkey ah
the doctor who has your wife it was
looks like an e Turkey complete basket
I'm in a cave test-tube ah [ __ ] ow not
funny
[ __ ] yeah I cut off your vagina you
don't have one yeah not time to explain
things later
[ __ ] your game vacation pictures it's
not close by you're about a trick man
this is the old way this isn't the
fountain they say yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ]
don't stop telling me to come closer
come how shy barely shut up connect [ __ ]
you what was that
no yes
hello girl no ah [ __ ] it
like oh this is find a way back I got
this yeah that's probably us is in here
so [ __ ] tired I could die out of
tiredness is that even possible
oh no oh okay oh my back
ah that's seriously hurt my guy ah okay
oh yeah myself right now what in the
heavens no but I'm your best friend
no you're not good [ __ ] Victor give
this to me and I promise I'll
get me out of my flea-ridden state
okay I saw a tarot card uh let's got
killed
uh okay what why are you on a table okay
huh I'm sorry about the echo in the
microphone I didn't notice it until now
that's a other than for the best dress
I've done for us
kal-el candolyn hello
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] out of [ __ ] I'm
not gonna pull that okay charging cycle
charging cycle yes all right
my friend go ahead boy